[Music]
so adele hasn't been talked about in a
minute I haven't seen her knee I thought
she was like baby-making and [ __ ] well
she got married right and then she had a
baby
I thought she lost a lot of weight
really yeah she has been sad enough to
make it now it's interesting she was fat
before marriage and then she got married
popped the kid out and got skinny it's
usually the opposite this is Joe
speaking rich and famous oh that's true
that's maybe that's what happens really
really popular her last album was in
2015 and last year she announced that
she said she was separating from her
husband perfect time she probably
complains too much like I got [ __ ]
work to do how I'm out here trying to
save the souls of the people that's been
through so many breakups or maybe in
order for her to make albums she needed
to get heartbreak so she manufactured a
heartbreak that's pretty good I like
that so the two artists dude makes the
best like soul music thing so you don't
say about Taylor Swift right we're Mara
every time she's like she dates a new
person break up with them make new songs
about them song sounds sad and Adele
feels like oh let me get some scotch
yeah [ __ ] cry about my breakups man
her songs are too sad for me I don't
think I'd ever get that's that you never
stood at a Starbucks line in a tear
rolled down your [ __ ] eye listening
to Adele [ __ ] no just sounds like fun
puppy come pick me up song we need to
pick me up like let's talk about [ __ ]
fish and chips or something about our
culture you know that likes to be too
sad I know man you are attractive the
sadness loves company
yeah so anyone who's sad or angry or
negative emotions like they need more of
it yeah that's bad so me I'm like if you
have it in your you got a moldy soul get
away from me
I like I like smile wait mold is good
though look at cheese I like cheese
here's my circle piece wrong crowd I'm
sorry to him I love cheese usually she's
okay anyway
parmesan
the reason why adele is making headlines
now or at least is in talks of in
twitter okay she cut off one of her toes
know what why she's in headlines I don't
know that would have been a headline
adele cut off one of her toes yeah
tries to join new album coming coming
out all this song usually labels her
albums as her age so in 2015 she was 25
she's she named the album 25 so what is
it no no 30 maybe 30 same hey I thought
she was 56 actually for real I thought
she was older than me do me too like I
was like this is a grown-ass woman
she sounds it to British so she just
feels like more sophisticated more older
more like but she sounds like she has
like four mortgages I know some immature
British people that paint on his first
blowing up and I didn't know what she
looked like I thought she was black
how does she have more pain than I do
out of that young ripe age she sounds
like she has pain of a divorced woman
that is in her mid 40 well she's getting
there so she is getting divorced so
recently there was okay this her net
worth is rumored to be a hundred and
forty million British pounds that's a
whole last company so that comes out to
about a hundred and seventy five almost
million dollars mmm so the headlines
initially they started reporting it as
Adele's a hundred and forty million
British pounds divorce which is
incorrect is incorrect yeah I'm not
taking her a whole net worth her whole
net worth
yeah they are they are saying that
because they don't exactly know how much
her net worth is they were saying that
she could possibly be worth a hundred
and ninety and so that's how they got
two hundred and forty for the divorce
settlement whatever the point is they
need to count all the piggy base and be
very careful the point is that the
internet the Twitter they grabbed this
number a hundred and forty million
dollar divorce or impound divorce and
they started saying
what the [ __ ] this man is gonna divorce
Adele and take a hundred and forty
million pounds from her that's insane
like what kind of divorce settlement is
that so then I sparked this whole is
this supposed to be 50/50 dad has a
hundred percent if it's a hundred and
forty if that is her actual net worth
and that is how much the settlement
comes out to that's a hundred percent of
her now oh so hot so but these are just
rumors it's not a fact and so that's why
people can't math because they're stupid
as [ __ ] right true right and you don't
know what she's like which is PMSing -
that's true you might be entitled to a
hundred percent might never know but
yeah so then uh your honor
you think she's emotional in her songs
oh my god okay so they're saying that
requests to keep details of her divorce
private had been granted by a court in
California so in California the laws are
that if you don't have a prenup you are
like the the when you split up whatever
amount was made during the course of the
marriage gets split up fifty-fifty okay
so whatever my baby way [ __ ] more
than he did right so then they're saying
that because of the fact that they don't
have a prenup they are supposed to be
split equally oh that's ugly but anyway
the whole conversation here is how can
this dude take her money like that much
money from her and then other people are
like the [ __ ] if Jeff Bezos can settle
with her ex with his ex for thirty
billion dollars when he divorced her
like why can't Adele settle for whatever
heard net worth is but equally so people
are saying like there's a gender
difference standard maybe
for most people's opinions there's a
double standard for their opinions yes
because they're do they have two kids
together I think they have a one kid
together and yeah I mean in the chef's
custody he has custody California is a
woman state so most likely she would be
a custody yeah but then it's Adele and
they know how emotional she is so they
might be like math I you know the thing
that's happening in California the thing
just to clarify the thing that is
happening in California is that the the
the request to keep the details of her
divorce private had been granted by a
court in California I don't know what I
don't know how else anything else is
being handled because a lot of this is
obviously very so she got divorced in
California but they're settling the
money in pounds yes that's the I don't
understand why they don't do this in
Britain where she is a native of that's
why I'm saying is just the point is we
don't have all the details and Twitter's
taking it into their own hands and
saying well he should have like get that
bad King please tell me what you think
12-year olds on Twitter please I think
it's like Oh cuz from what I've seen
it's more just about he's getting 50%
right and that guys the girls are
getting everyone's getting mad that why
does he cuz he didn't do [ __ ] for her
see them music career I mean that
happens to with win wives get [ __ ] like
gold like gold digger like your
stereotypical like super hot
you know ex-porn star or whatever my
happens both way it has it happened like
I am gigolo guy the wife breaks off like
with like Tiger Woods and his wife I
mean even though he [ __ ] up but like
it would have had I did they separate I
think they separated okay Tiger Woods
anyway yeah for sure okay it's hard to
say what they're entitled to because I
don't know cuz every relationship is
different right like in their case he
could have been a big [ __ ] emotional
support that helped her create the
content that she did or you know even
just being in close proximity with
someone your boundaries are bouncing
back ideas with them and they're helping
you in some way shape or form right so
it's hard to say if they're entitled or
not like there's so much [ __ ] that goes
down and you don't know if what he did
to help
her made that million well Saturday
career it moves too it's like how much
of your own career you give up when you
enter that marriage to back her up yeah
that's how you have like a housewife or
whatever it's like oh I gave up my car
five years ago how am I supposed to jump
back in you know it's been five years
since I've been like an accountant or
whatever you know you don't seem kind of
conceited asphere is going crazy it's
like but do you need 140 million pounds
that's rumored also to be her no yeah
that that that sounds crazy like a
hundred percent and it's net worth
that's not cash that's how stupid these
[ __ ] are they don't know the
difference true what's that slice huh
that's a different okay so for example
you are a partner you are a partner to
one to our restaurants right so because
you're a partner to all this stuff
you own a percentage now your net worth
goes up so if people calculated that the
worth of that and said hey Casey you you
own Casey and TIFF
owns like a percentage of this in theory
if that company sells you are two
thousand there or whatever right and
this is how a lot of absent and these
guys have a lot of money or a met worth
right so like let's say I develop an app
call it like bitter or some [ __ ] where
people complain all day bitter right and
then it people will value it maybe it
might not make any dollars this is how
Facebook and a lot of these guys made
money is because it doesn't have [ __ ]
money but it has users it has data it
has all this [ __ ] right and so your net
worth is in the millions of maybe in the
billions with your net worth you could
go to the bank and get a loan out so
technically these guys are [ __ ] broke
but they have yachts they have cars they
have mansions because the bank is is
basically there they're risking this
money that they give you on a loan and
then they'll be like use this money
because I know you're good for it when
you sell this bitter company everyone
wants to [ __ ] buy it and when you
sell it you could pay us back so what
people don't know is that these guys
don't got no [ __ ] cash they're
millionaires with no cash at
they're just loans and whatever so
that's the difference between like you
can have something and that's net worth
you you you have assets so you have
things that are worth something to other
people but unless you turned it into
liquid which is cash cold hard cash you
don't actually have the money so Adele
might have only a million in her bank
account and she might have a bunch of
who knows businesses one of her
properties that she recently sold one of
her properties in the UK at a 1 million
pound loss yeah the reason why just to
clarify the reason why she filed for
divorce in California is because they
actually live here and he has a home
near her so they can better co-parent
their seven-year-old yeah so oh yeah
that's the difference between the two
things and you know the real divorces
get [ __ ] nasty and [ __ ] but sometimes
it's the best way you guys can come up
and and you want to buy a cheap house
you go to a couple of that says hey
you're gonna divorce I'll [ __ ] fire
house real quick I'll do it for cheaper
too you know and they'll be like [ __ ]
I just want to get rid of this thing I
bought it for a million but we can't
[ __ ] stand each other I'll sell it to
you for 500,000 and and then they'll
split that that's that kind of [ __ ]
happens a lot too so technically that
might not be what he's getting so
there's a that's a difference between
cash and net worth
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]